1 2 3 ça va l'urbane looupe est sur la
bonne voie ce mardi 19 décembre le
ministre des Transports clémentbaun
était à l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline présentation du
véhicule et pause du premier rail un
moment symbolique pour annoncer
l'expérimentation de ce nouveau moyen de
transport pour les Jeux Olympiques 2024
un circuit de 2 km desservant le grand
parking lieu de la future Fan Zone et un
site d'hébergement au niveau du Relais
Des canardières c'est une très belle
innovation pour les transports et pour
les mobilités C innovation qui est
électrique C innovation française qui
associe l'Université des entrepreneurs
des élus et Saint-Quentin a été
justement au rendez-vous dès le départ
maintenant nous sommes prêts et c'est
important d'être à l'heure des Jeux
Olympiques parce que c'est le moment où
on va pouvoir avoir assez de voyageurs
pour expérimenter ce qui est aujourd'hui
mobilité totalement innovante et encore
une fois décarbonée donc qui participe à
ces grands objectifs qu'on se fixe de
sobriété alimenté par un courant de très
basse tension dans les rails les 10
futures capsules seront autonomes et
pilotées par des algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle elles
pourront accueillir chacune deux
passagers un trajet écologique à 50 km/h
à moins d'un centime d'eurau le
kilomètre curban loop c'est un système
de transport qui est dédié au zone de
moyenne densité c'estd pas le
centreville de Paris par le
centrre-ville de Marseille mais des
villes comme saint-ctin niveline où on
souhaite être plus rapide que la voiture
on ne fait pas d' tentequé il y a
toujours des véhicules qui viennent se
recharger comme des télécabines sur les
dans les stations on arrive on rentre on
appuie sur la station ou sur laquelle on
souhaite aller les portes se ferment et
après le véhicule va directement à sa
destination sans s'arrêter débuté en
septembre 2023 les travaux se
poursuivront jusqu'à la mi-janvier avec
la pose des derniers rails les navettes
hyperloop seront testées à vide dès
février avec une ouverture au public à
la fin du printemps cette
expérimentation de 17 mois d'un coût de
5 millions d'euros est financée à
hauteur de 800000 € par l'agglomération
de Saint-Quentin en yvelinevel